tig
i was so thrilled when i heard that you
had signed on for this one
what would you say was the key to
jumping into a project like this
so late in the game and filming your
scenes in such a unique way
but making sure that it all fits into
the final film seamlessly which
i was so impressed that you all did here
well that's how i do all my work as
i'm always green screened in to
everything
and uh that's not true but i i think it
was just
um um his
his authenticity his um
his uh his talents the script
the enthusiasm behind it all uh
the excitement that i had for trying
something
so not just a new genre for me but
um to be green screened in i felt like
i'm always you know how a lot of people
would say look i'm not here to make
friends
i am solely showing up places to make
friends
and so this felt like the best
chance that i could show up and have
what could be a ridiculous time and i
was
asking zach like can you promise me that
you will laugh
in the moments that this seems so
utterly insane
and uh and he he promised me all of
those things
and and delivered and it was
it was just really really fun
um and uh he's a huge selling point
not just because he's zack snyder but
because he's
he's zack snyder he's just he's so solid